Daniel: Greetings, Ines!
Ines: Hello.
Daniel: Welcome.
Ines: Hi, Daniel.
Thank you.
Daniel: Yes, well, we're really looking
forward to your presentation.
You can share your slides and go for it.
Ines: Great.
It can you see it?
Daniel: Yes.
Looks great.
Thank you.
Ines: All right, good.
So thank you so much for having me.
I'm really happy to present this paper
today, and particularly because it's the
very first time that I present this work.
.
So I'm really looking forward to any
feedback and any reactions to this work.
OK, so the aim of this paper was to apply
the free energy principle to analyze the
interdependent dynamics between living
systems on the one hand, and nonliving
planetary processes.
And this, hopefully, would, we hope,
allow us to gain some insights into the
future states of Gaia.
And by Gaia we're going to mean the Earth
and formulate some predictions and devise
potential interventions to alleviate
future dysfunction on the planet.
Okay?
So then the lineup for the presentation
is I'm first going to go over, in brief,
the theory, the concept of Gaia, so known
as the Gaia hypothesis.
Then I'm going to go into just giving
some essentials on the free energy
principle, which I'm assuming that it's
not really necessary, but just for the
sake of the flow of my argument.
Then I'm just going to present some
things on the free energy principle and
specifically on self organizing
interacting systems.
And then I'm going to apply the free
energy principle to the Gaia poses is in
a sort of like comparison analysis, as in
how do they, if at all, complement each
other for epistemic gain?
And then after having done that, this
should be should allow us to inform or to
gain some insights as per the human
behavior in relation to Gaia or the
planet Earth.
Okay, so let's see how it goes.
So first I want to introduce the notion
of biophilia, which plays a fundamental
role in this work.
So biophilia came first, or came more
prominently in this particular book here,
and it's quite interesting.
The idea is that the relation of humanity
to the rest of the natural world is
essentially one of dependence.
And this is very much already in the
literature and the free energy principle.
.
But more than that, there is this view of
the necessity of a continued survival and
flourishing that is utterly contingent
upon the state and functioning of the
environment.
So we're talking about things like very
utilitarian things like survival,
flourishing, mental health, right?
So individuals interact with the
environment.
So to achieve that, but then on top of
that, we wanted to add another conceptual
layer which is or concerns how humans
possess an innate cognitive disposition
towards nature, which is known and
developed in this particular other field
of work as biophilia.
And this is the idea of the natural
psychological disposition of humans to
seek out and connect with other living
organisms and the natural environment.
So that's kind of like the idea that is
encapsulated in the whole framework and
theory under biophilia.
So then this seems to if that's the case
of as things are described by biophilia,
then that seems to bring us to a dilemma.
.
On the one hand, we have these natural
tendencies, so to speak, of humans to
engage with the natural world in a very
positive and constructive way.
And on the other hand we see the lack of
action to protect the Earth.
And here we have in mind particularly the
case of the climate crisis.
So in the presentation I'm going to make
my way slowly towards getting to that and
to better understand the dilemma.
Okay?
So let's go in brief over the Gaia
hypotheses.
So this is a concept that comes more
prominently in James Loflock's book Gaia
a New Look at Life on Earth.
And the idea there is that 3.8 billion
years that life has persisted on Earth
and conditions have remained remarkably
constant and favorable across a huge
range of parameters.
The Gaia hypothesis is that this
consistency or constancy is a natural
product of evolution.
In a modification, however, of the
canonical Darwinism, the Gaia hypothesis
somewhat modifies canonical Darwinism
how?
Well, by thinking that rather than
evolution of the individual organisms on
an inert environment, what evolves is the
whole Earth system with its living and
nonliving parts existing as a tight
coupled entity.
So this is the kind of like, so to speak,
refreshing or new way of thinking that
somewhat reformulated a little bit of
Darwinism, right?
The emphasis is not how one individual
organism evolves or species evolves, but
the whole Earth as a system.
So that's quite interesting because, for
example, the view that the combined
genetic wealth of information of the
whole system becomes much more prominent
here than the Darwinistic kind of view
and this acquires characteristics that
are conductive to its continued existence
and in turn affect changes on the
environment.
So then, seen as a whole organism or as a
whole system, one can look at Gaia or the
Earth as a complex system which appears
to have the goal of regulating the
climate and the chemistry at a
comfortable state of life.
And these views and these ideas have come
to gain more official expression in 2001
with the Amsterdam Declaration on Earth
system science precisely endorsing this
view on the planet Earth as a whole
system.
So then the Gaia hypothesis is a complex
system in various ways because it changes
in an adaptive and nonlinear way.
It also displays dynamical emergent and
sudden tipping behavior.
And when bifurcation points are reached,
the new tractor states form, new tractor
states are formed.
And this means that it also self
organizes and there is interdependence
between the processors of the system.
And finally, the Gaia hypothesis seems to
be quite interesting and extraordinary in
the sense that it brings together so many
different fields such as ecology, climate
science, cybernetics, complex systems
theory, chaos, mathematics and philosophy
of mine and that's just a few.
All right.
So then the idea is of the Gaia
hypothesis is that we could look at the
planet from orbit or as it is known, the
overview effect.
And the Gaia hypothesis offers this
glimpse of a fundamentally different way
of thinking of the planet, of thinking
that in fact dominated mostly by human
history.
So it's a little bit of like that very
inspiring clip by Karl Sagan, the Pale
blue dot whereby the world is considered.
.
So throughout the human history there's
typically a tendency for the world or the
planet to be considered from a single
living organism, though, rather than an
it.
So that's the idea of overview effect and
taking this overview effect to look at
the planet as this whole living system
rather than an it.
Okay?
So then we can think about the Gaia
hypotheses as like Newtonian physics or
even as the free energy principle.
The Gaia hypotheses can be seen much more
as a framework or a method of
investigation rather than a falsifiable
empirical claim.
So in this sense, these particular
frameworks, they are and should be judged
by their usefulness and not by their
purported correctness with usefulness.
Importantly, usefulness is to be
determined by factors such as parsimony,
coherence and consistency plus its
empirical and epistemic power to explain
phenomena, produce new facts and so on in
a given context and at a given time frame.
.
So that's the stance that we think that
should be taken on the Gaia hypothesis.
All right?
So now having said a few words on the
Gaia hypothesis now I'm going to just
prepare the stage by saying a few words
on the Fiang principle which, given the
topic of this conference, needs no
introduction.
But for these purposes I must mention
just a few things.
So the Fiang principle, we take it to be
the case as well that it is a methodology
to understand overserved patterns of
behavior sorry, observed patterns of
behavior in the natural world.
So then we apply the free energy
principle as the tool and methodology to
analyze these interdependent dynamics
between living systems and planetary
processes, right?
Kind of like these goggles, these
methodological, technical, scientific
goggles that you put on to gain insights
into the future states of Gaia or the
Earth such as to make future formulate
predictions and devise potential
interventions in this particular case
with the care of alleviating future
potential or present dysfunction.
Okay, so the free energy principle very
much aligns with this thinking by Ewan
Schwellinger and the view that the second
law of thermodynamics or under the second
law of thermodynamics that open systems
like us should tend to dissipation.
However interestingly, there are displays
of this super cool thing, the negantropy,
which are pockets of the universe where
order and bodily integrity are maintained
in the face of the surge towards chaos or
towards entropy or towards dissipation.
And this view of the pockets of the
universe is incredibly interesting
because this is where we find self
organizing systems like us.
And what is so peculiar that
distinguishes these self organizing
living systems from nonliving systems is
that they have the capacity of acting
upon and exchanging matter, energy or
information with the environment in order
to seemingly defy the second law and
therefore or thereby avoid dissipation
and chaos and entropy.
So that's extraordinary.
So then active inference becomes this
very useful tool to tell us or to explain
elucidate how these systems seemingly
defy the second law, how they resist
entropy, how the self organizing systems
combat entropy through the interaction,
maintaining their integrity via
homeostasis.
So then they maintain this energetic
integrity.
They utilize energy to stay within a
specific range of states that is vital
for their survival and preserving their
existence.
And they also engage with these feedback
cycles which are the feedback actions
like drinking when thirsty or moving away
from heat signify working, accomplished
by bound energy, contrasting with the
free energy.
They also define the thermodynamics, as I
just mentioned, by seemingly challenging
the law, they minimize entropy and
safeguard their free energy.
And finally this behavior that we observe
in these self organizing living systems
in striving to minimize free energy is or
agrees with a certain principle that we
know, which is the free energy principle.
.
Okay?
So then, as I said earlier and as we know
but just to keep in mind then active
inference becomes a very useful tool to
understand and make predictions about
these coupling dynamics taking place
between interacting systems, living
systems.
Internal states is both operationally
closed and thermodynamically open to the
external states creating this distinct
boundary which we usually mathematically
capture with Markov blanket.
And then this interaction unfolds through
the immediate of active and sensory
states.
Then the key point here to keep in mind
is that what we want to have for
adaptation and well being is that there
is a balanced interaction between sensory
and active states.
And this is because it is within the
interaction between sensory and active
states that so to speak, all of the
important things happen in order for the
system to be well adjusted attuned
adapted to the environment.
So living systems avoid this dissipation.
.
They want to remain alive, they do
everything in their power, they navigate
their environments in order to avoid this
dissipation which is also or can be also
said to minimize free energy.
And they avoid their dissipation by doing
either one of the two things either by
changing the model or changing the world,
by acting upon the world.
And this is extremely crucial for the
point that I want to make later on.
So now I want to apply the Fionergy
principle to the Guy hypothesis and see
how that comes together in identifying
and developing and why do I want to do
that?
I want to do that because I've also
already mentioned it.
But I'm just going to refresh it because
I want to identify and develop
interventions to rectify any potential
maladaptive responses, namely actions
which are antithetical to maintaining the
integrity of the system.
What we want is to have healthy, well
adjusted adaptive systems and human
behavior particularly that leads to the
imbalance within the Markov blanket
states, is or could be considered
sometimes maladaptive or pathological.
And this will be the last point I'm going
to make in the presentation, but for now
want to focus on how does the French
principle deal with the Gaia hypothesis
as a self organizing system like Ruth?
Just saying.
The Gaia meets the requirements to be
formalized as part of an active inference
system.
It exists in a non equilibrium steady
state, which means that its processes and
states must persist over time within a
range of states that are far from
equilibrium.
That means resisting entropy.
And the Gaia is also distinguishable from
its largest scale cosmic environment such
as other planets and the rest of the
universe.
It is also defined by the conditional
independence that we were just talking
about between the internal and external
stage which influence each other only
vicariously.
So then we can taking that into
consideration, we can even see that some
of the people have already done this kind
of like line of reasoning, they've
already run it through and they did that
by employing Markov blanket to analyze
the Earth's climate system dynamics,
which is quite interesting.
What they did was they looked at
metabolic rates of the biosphere and they
represented them as internal states and
space weather as external states and then
they looked at active states as mirrored
greenhouse effect shifts and sensory
states as echoed ocean driven temperature
changes and then internal and external
states.
The idea here is that they indirectly
influenced each other through ocean's
delayed response.
Then Earth's climate is interpreted as
anticipatory minimizing variational, free
energy.
So we take this work and we want to take
it a step further agreeing with this work
and building upon this work which shows
climate change, we wanted to look at the
more broad understanding of Gaia through
the lenses of the free energy principle.
So instead of focusing on climate change,
which is very brilliantly done by these
researchers, we wanted to then scale it
up and apply the free energy principle to
understand the Gaia.
So then one can think of the internal
states as the biosphere geographical
processes and the external states as
everything that is beyond the system,
such as the outer atmosphere, Celicia
bodies and molten core.
Then we can think of sensory states as
the external environment impact such as
the Earth rotation, orbit, tides affected
by the sun, moon, planets, plate
tectonics, climate, weather influenced by
solar radiation, space weather, etc.
So and then we can think of the active
states as Earth's adaptability and
adjusting properties from external
influence such as gravitational force,
altars orbits, magnetic field interacts
with solar winds or emission of
detectable radiation influences distant
objects.
That's a few examples.
So then I want to focus on the active
states.
Active states then through this lens,
active states then embody its primary
mechanism for self regulation,
representing its efforts to remain within
the bounds required for ongoing existence
based on predictions about the present
and future states of the system.
For instance, the current levels of
greenhouse and albedo effects, soil PH
and the number of living organisms
reflect the predictive attempts of the
Gaia system to adapt to anticipated
effects of solar events, volcanic
eruptions, ocean salinity changes, and
other environmental factors in the future.
.
So it is in this context that the role of
life itself assumes a paramount
importance in the self regulation of the
biosphere.
Because the role of life itself, and
particularly as we are going to focus on
next, the human life, has a particular
influence on all of these sort of already
natural dynamics going on in the gaia.
This allows us, before we move into the
human effects, this allows us to make one
final point before we move there, which
is to address the criticism that has been
made in this paper by Vicente Haja on the
Markov blanket trick.
And what they have identified is that a
purported weakness of the free energy
principle what we say is that a weakness
of the free energy principle that is
identified in this paper actually speaks
in favor of its application to the Gaia
hypothesis.
And let me just try to explain that.
So Raja and colleagues, they rightly
point out that Markov Lincolns do not
automatically capture every relevant
property of biological systems,
relational properties such as affordances.
.
And by affordances they mean what the
environment offers, the animal, what it
provides, or furnishes, either good or
evil fall into this bracket.
So what they're saying is that Markov
blanket do not automatically capture
every relevant aspect of biological
system such as affordances, right?
And we want to point out that however,
affordances correspond to Gaia as one
rung in the ladder of the Nested Marco
blankets within the system in question at
every level ranging up from, say, cells,
organs, animals, ecosystems, solar
systems, the whole cosmos.
And how is it that we think that this
particular framework that we bring here
does have or solve or address the notion
of affordances?
Our solar system is one that affords a
living planet.
So the affordance available is an
environment.
In an environment are not determined
solely by the physical properties of the
environment.
And we think that this is the point that
we would like to address in HaHa's paper,
is that the affordances are not
determined solely by the physical
properties of the environment, but also
by the organism's goals, abilities and
previous experiences and in this case, of
the sun.
So what is meant here is that the sun is
what has the furnaces for or what affords
anything else to happen on the planet at
whatever each scale, right?
The physical properties of the sun as
well as the goals and abilities of the
organisms on earth shape the affordances
that the sun provides.
So it's a quite interesting way of
thinking that any affordance whatsoever
that we might think of that we have as
living systems, they are afforded by the
sun.
So that's the idea.
Okay, so now having gone through how the
female G principle somewhat speaks to and
contributes to understanding the Gaia
hypotheses, then we want to focus on how
human behavior has a profound effect on
the dynamics that already existing in the
natural world.
Daniel: Okay?
Ines: So according to the frequencies
principle, living beings have a natural
tendency to act upon their environment to
prevent dissipation of their integrity.
So that's what we do in order to remain
alive.
There are therefore two ways for a thing
like us to minimize its free energy and
thereby maintain our own integrity upon
evidence.
As we navigate the world and gather and
observe evidence, we have two options.
One is to change the model.
The other one is to change the world by
acting upon it, like I just said before.
So then why is this relevant?
Well, this is relevant because there is
the possibility that in the ways in which
living systems and in this particular
case human beings interact and adapt to
the world, there is the possibility that
we see maladaptive behavior.
And how would that be?
Well, if it is the case that there is a
rejection of the information available so
as to remove the imperative for action or
if it is the case that possessing the
information available but we still remain
or refrain from taking action, then there
seems to be if the free energy principle
is correct if the free energy principle
is to be correct, that systems, living
beings tend to act upon the world in
order to remain alive and if it is the
case that one rejects that kind of
information and does not take action to
remain alive, such as the information of
the climate crisis, then we might be
looking at maladaptive behavior.
So if the free energy principle holds,
then the observed contradictory behavior
is a maladaptive state or should be seen
as a maladaptive state that arises from
an imbalance within the Markov blanket.
And how do we see this imbalance within
the Markov blanket?
We see it to put it in very, very simple
terms, we see it as an insulation of
internal states that are not being
affected by the information available
outside of the system.
So the influences or the interactions are
occurring between internal, active and
sensory states.
And this is an imbalance that results in
an insulation or an echo chamber effect
in internal states that are impermeable
to the information from or potentially
existing in the external states that
demands action.
So then some food for thought.
What can we make of this?
The free energy principle?
If we are to use the free energy
principle to model the dynamics of the
relationships between humans and the
environment then we think that it is
possible to see the current lack of pro
environmental behavior as a pathology of
the human species that must receive
treatment.
We label this condition as Biophilia
Deficiency Deficiency Syndrome.
Biophilia Deficiency Syndrome and it is
important for us to focus on that to
construct some validity.
Is useful to consider in this case other
applications of the free energy principle
that may be useful as an analogous case
of pathology mainly conducted in
psychiatry and neurology and in here and
very short because I don't have time.
The idea is to see it as a failure to
assign the right way or prediction to
prediction errors.
So then the free energy principle from
this point of view this is a persuasive
pathology because doing nothing is a base
optimal response in the face of
pathological attention to various sources
of evidence.
So evidence is ignored.
So concluding and recapping according to
the free energy principle living systems
possess a biological encoded inclination
to interact with the environment in order
to survive and adapt to the environment.
And despite the climate change being a
pressing issue and the information being
available the evidence being available
proactive measures to reverse its effects
are not giving the priority they deserve.
.
This state of affairs seems to show very
clearly a divergence from a natural
inclination that we call biophilia or
that is existing in the literature as
biophilia.
This discrepancy between the expected and
the observed actions can be understood in
the framework of the free energy
principle or so we think.
As an illness, it implies that systems,
including human societies may form
erroneous inferences that prevent them
from effectively addressing the problem
at hand.
Now, thinking about future directions and
this is my last slide current ecological
imbalances could be thought of as a stuck
state that require an active disturbance
to bring about some change.
A stuck state is a state that a system is
at a local minimum where the system is at
and won't get out of that state unless it
is disturbed.
So that's the principle in complex
systems theory and we think that that's
how this particular state should be
looked at.
But that's for future research.
And what we would be calling is we would
be calling for amounts to the kind of
homeostatic awakening.
So the sort of like getting out of this
stuck state would require some kind of
like omniostatic awakening a deliberately
induced disruptive shift in the
trajectory reflecting a prioritization of
the planetary homeostasis over infinite
growth or staying in the same place.
And yeah, this is my last slide.
Thank you so much.
I would like also to acknowledge my co
author Casper Montgomery.
Thank you so much for your attention.
Daniel: Thank you.
Well, a lot of ways to go.
I'll just ask one question just in the
years that you've been in the game how do
you see the active inference ecosystem
and the ways also that it's being applied
to ecosystems evolving, like, over what
timescales or in what ways does that
really present itself to you?
Ines: Slow, sadly slow.
I think there's a lot of work that needs
to be done.
We try to do this particular one here to
apply employ active inference to the
planet or the Earth as a living system
precisely to bring out or to overcome.
One is to look at this problem of the
climate crisis as what we think it is,
which is more of a pathology.
If the free energy principle holds, then
it seems that there is maladaptive
behavior of the collective of the human
species.
So I think that there's a lot of work
that can be done and that would very much
be useful in the climate crisis in
general.
There is some other work that came out
more recently by Maxwell and colleagues
as well on the ecosystems, which is
really cool.
And I would also mention that one, and I
really hope that we can pursue this line
of research and employee active inference
in the free energy principle to this
particular case.
One of the things that really attracts me
to the free energy principle is the
capacity that it has to bring to the
forefront certain laws of physics, but
also the living systems navigating and
interacting with their environments,
which I find much more appealing than any
computational framework per se.
So that's what I find that it's a very
useful conceptual toolkit that I think
that I would really like to see more
applied in the future for the climate
crisis and the Earth.
Daniel: Great.
Well, thank you so much for building on
that line of work and for sharing it with
us tonight.
Ines: Thank you so much for having me.
Daniel: Till next time.
See you.
Ines: Thank you.
Daniel: Bye bye.
All right, well, great talk by an S.
Bye.